this belief that the world is entirely
independent of our minds and objective
and unaware of us is the kind of science
scientific fiction in which we operate
and then the real truth that appears to
our perceptions the truth of our
immediate experience is that the the
mind is a concentric field of
diminishing intensity that can draw
events and circumstances far from the
ranges of probability I mean I had once
I had the following experience it's all
anecdotal you see I was in a dry wash in
the Negev desert and there was
absolutely no food and I was poor
traveling hit the Machine and the cave
dweller and then there do well and it
was like a hundred and twenty degrees
outside my cave and I was sitting in
front of my cave smoking hash and out
through the shimmering heat I could see
this dot of a person
and I watched them making their way
through the rocks and the scrub I began
to have a fantasy about this vision that
they had food that they didn't simply
have food that that they had Oysters
Rockefeller packed in ice that they had
Russian caviar that they had Belgian
chocolate that they had all of this
stuff and you know I haven't had a bath
in three weeks that was barely any water
in this place and this speck made its
way toward me getting larger and larger
and finally it turned into this guy I
barely knew a fellow lost soul this was
hidden southern Israel twenty-five years
ago any sit and he came up to me and he
said I have oysters packed in ice I have
Belgian chocolate I and he had gotten a
job dishwashing that morning at the King
David hotel and had just quit in disgust
halfway through the day and had raided
this super fancy four-star hotel and
just had a backpack full of this stuff
and I didn't even bother to tell him
what am I gonna say you know I mean sure
of course
so these kinds of things
and they're very private you see nothing
happens there except that a guy quits
his job and rips off a hotel except that
it is coincident with an internal state
a private musing of somebody else and
when the two things come together the
coincidence of it is absolutely
excruciating